parliament will set out its position on
a raft of ambitious climate clause the
fit for 55 package is designed to cut
greenhouse gas emissions and achieve
climate neutrality by 2050. the
proposals include better use of land
emissions trading schemes and help for
those affected by energy poverty
meps will discuss russia's war in
ukraine with the speaker of the
ukrainian parliament as well as the
latest round of eu sanctions the
european parliament is expected to
demand more support for kiev stronger eu
defence capabilities and ways to reduce
energy dependence
parliament is set to propose changes to
the eu's law making process giving it
the right to initiate legislation meps
have long argued that the move would
strengthen democracy and restore balance
between the eu institutions
the winner of the lux audience award
will be announced in the presence of
representatives of the three shortlisted
films
flee great freedom and quovardus ida
european cinema lovers and meps have
been casting votes for their favourites
with each group weighing 50 percent
meps will vote on giving more powers to
europol the eu's law enforcement agency
to help police and judicial cooperation
in criminal investigations it would
facilitate cooperation between national
authorities especially customs and at
borders
[Music]